elle s'habille comme lui d'un pantalon
d'un blouson quand on les rencontre
la nuit on dirait deux garçons leurs
visages jeu paraît figé
comment deviner qu'il sert eux ils ont
des jeux donc je veux c'est là qu'il
veut leur joie c'est le temps et
n'importe qui âge tendre et tête de bois
gilbert bécaud depuis cette chanson il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses dans la
chanson il ya de la concurrence
maintenant plus en plus jeune aurait pas
de concurrence
c'est pas de la concurrence on la
pensait un moment donné ben on pense
toujours à concurrence est amusant la
concurrence d'ailleurs ce qui est bien
la concurrence et que ça vous fait
possible la qualité toujours en toile on
n'a pas eu peur un peu hors bombe a
toujours peur enfin peur non on a
toujours on se demande toujours ce qu'il
va se passer mais c'est surtout pour eux
on a beaucoup fait de polémique autour
d'ailleurs de ces jeunes qui chantent
qui sont plus en plus jeunes oui mais
c'est bien moi je trouve ça très vieux
je sens que voudriez faire dire que cela
m'a porté tort et vraiment il n'est pas
question oui et puis ainsi de 7 ce qui
se passe autour d'eux est très très bien
je trouve ça fasse a remué c'est
agréable
puis vous savez moi personnellement
j'ai fait vraiment tout ce que je
pouvais pour les aider plutôt bien et
pousse très vite dans quelques semaines
en quelques mois on parle devant deux
chiffres de ventes de disques famille
notre histoire quelle histoire
vous savez les chiffres énoncés
quelquefois sans du domaine de la
publicité
il s'en faut les dire ah je ne veux pas
dire qu'il soit fort parce que je les
connais pas mais je veux dire
ils sont sûrement ils sont sûrement à
allonger ou et sûrement sans doute enfin
je ne je ne pourrais pas l'affirmer mais
je le pense
mais ces jeunes gens qui chantent qui se
met à chanter très vite comme ça on
pourrait penser aussi qu'ils n'ont pas
de métier ne pensez pas que les jambes
les plus professionnels que par c'est un
bien grand mot professionnel permet
quand même quelquefois oui mais avant
tout c'est une belle histoire
on peut l'apprendre à huit jours comme
ça on peut sans doute là pendant huit
jours mais peut-on la conserver plus de
huit jours ce sera quel problème voulait
dire que ça ne dure pas ça peut ne pas
durer et d'ailleurs c'est le problème
des jeunes la grille de connaissent et
ces choses là c'est terry parce que
quand tout avait un jeune à qui vous
donnez
quand même beaucoup d'argent pour
chanter le soir et qui dit jour au
lendemain qui quitte son travail et qui
du jour au lendemain on gagne pas mal
d'argent
comme on ya j'ai dû si un jour cette
chose là s'arrête qu'est ce qui va
devenir
c'est un problème pour vos débuts ça
s'est passé de cette façon-là d'argent
très vite
ah non moi c'est pas la même chose de
toute façon c'est pas même chose parce
que je mon intention était de chanter
pendant 25 ans et je ne suis qu'à aux
demies parcours vous voulez durée je ne
veux pas je dirais oui j'écris une
chanson comme ça qu'il faut faire pour
durer l x de sincère vous êtes sûr de
durée je m'en fous mais je dirais il car
je suis sincère au début on vous appeler
monsieur cent mille volts vous souvenez
web on appelle toujours de cette année
on appelle que j'en perds cinq mille
volts mais depuis il ya eu il ya eu du
survoltage si je puis dire
johnny hallyday c'est au moins un
million de volts ah oui mais ça on m'a
dit ce qu'on m'a dit vous calmez vous
c'est mieux vous vous calmez vous
n'aimez pas du tout c'est vous qui vous
habituer à moi mais je ne suis pas enfin
je suis peut-être calmer vous avez il
est très difficile de demander à
quelqu'un de parler de lui mais ce sera
difficile
qu'est ce que ça change bonne forme
qu'est ce que ça veut dire se calmer bas
par rapport aux gens c'est par rapport à
quelqu'un ou quelque chose sur non pas
moi j'évolue de calme et j'ai pas
l'impression d'être enfin johnny
hallyday il est moins calme que vous
maintenant on s'aime vous savez si je
vous disais que je ne vais jamais vu je
connais bien personnellement mais je les
avais vus en scène enfin évidemment ça
c'est autre chose maintenant vous allez
faire un nouveau tour de chant à paris
dans quelques semaines oui je vais à
l'olympia avec de nouvelles chansons
avec beaucoup de nouvelles chansons et
de même qu'on a été les premiers
entendre tête devant vrai projet
imposerait de nouvelles chansons qui
s'appelle comment vous savez toute
nouvelle je la connais pas très bien
ça s'appelle toi
oh
pour toi que j'attendais depuis
longtemps déjà
voir dans cette foule d'inconnus
je t'ai reconnu toi que j'espérais
depuis longtemps déjà
toi
dans cette foule de perdus je t'ai
reconnue
et les chambres
le toit riel
à la vessie il me parlait
les toits aussi plurielle
chambres et plus le réel
toi que je savais depuis longtemps pour
moi
toi dans cet open le dégât n'est
gaspillée
toi
j'aurais voulu tendre les mains des
doigts
voir
j'aurais voulu tenter d'expliquer
ses jambes
ouah
c'est un pc pas connaître
mais toi aussi tu riais
mise en oreille
pour
voir alexis minable du temps à la
toi dans le château de feuilles
chaque héros terres 10
il
m